est ce que vous vous pourrez rejoindre
ce groupe d constructif absolument pas
absolument pas d'abord parce que en tant
que républicain je suis aussi nara
depuis douze ans et depuis 12 ans j'ai
voté pour ou contre des mesures
proposées par les gouvernements de
droite ou de gauche et au sénat je n'ai
pas je ne suis pas seule dans mon groupe
on a voté un certain nombre de
dispositions qui ne sont pas c'est
d'ailleurs qu'avec les républicains sous
le gouvernement hollande quand on
estimait que ces mesures étaient bonnes
et on a voté contre parfois des
dispositions qui étaient proposées par
le gouvernement à l'époque de sarkozy
parce qu'on estimait que c'était pas
bonnes donc être constructif ce n'est
pas s'appeler c'est pas se donner une
terminologie c'est le traduire dans les
actes
alors si être constructif c'est dire je
vote 100 % de ce que propose le
gouvernement
dans ces cas là on va à la république
est en marche donc vous vous êtes et
vous restez dans l'opposition au
gouvernement je reste dans une
opposition au gouvernement en fonction
des textes qui nous sont proposés
regardez sur les dispositions sur les
ordonnances sur le travail le travail
nous les avons voté nous avons voté le
texte sur ce qui s'appelait auparavant
la moralisation de la vie politique en
l'aménageant et c'est même demeurer
après par l'assemblée nationale alors
que la majorité est république en marche
donc ça veut dire que l'on fait avancer
les textes dans le sens qu'il convient
aux citoyens et c'est comme ça que
j'entends ma mission de sénateur quel
que soit mon étiquette et c'est pour ça
que je n'aurais pas l'étiquette
constructif